Elizabeth Banks being honored tonight
first female director to receive this
honor in your words why is she yes why
why is she is such a better well you'll
see in our speeches yeah we don't want
to give it all away dude liz is this was
a storyteller she's like a compulsive
artist and she like has the balls to do
it in a way that is unique to her and
like her professional personal nonprofit
endeavours it just suck in tonight is
just such an incredible even positive
what with buzzin to know she's
incredible I was just thinking about
whenever there's a group of three you
can't help it if you're taking a picture
to do the pose like every group of
friends does the Charlie's Angels pose
when there's three of you do you know
what's funny never have I well I've seen
ones where they hold it like this where
they go for good thing I've done it in
my lifetime but particularly Nova's
movie
I never go entirely of our own like our
own version of it almost like you know
either our own oh yeah yeah and so on
and the trailer kind of and then there's
bill one that we do without saying any
spoilers that moment yeah on that one I
have no idea what she's that smile no
least song of the summer don't call me
angel
it's been completely stuck in my head
since I came out I mean I don't know if
you guys feel the same I would like
everyone to stop posting that song
because I can't literally I'm like I
can't get away from it I actually what I
mean is like these angels is sick and I
love that song and I do but like it's a
lot I think what we're trying to say is
it gets in your head I mean I literally
wake up and that song is in my head and
I'm not just saying that
it literally means we haven't I haven't
heard all of it so I only have like yeah
you can hear all of it it might be a
satisfying experience with me I happened
say I I have full volume bled that out
of my car driving down the road so yeah
and imitating the Miley Cyrus but that's
what I was what's up guys thank you for
being on our sound ride
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]